CHRIS: Hi everyone.
My name is Chris.
I'm a friend of science.
And I usually start by saying,
welcome to the NASA, da da da
da.
But it's not NASA
this time, it's ESA.
He's from Europe.
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: No,
I'm from an island
just off the coast of Europe.
CHRIS: He's from an island
off the coast of Europe.
But he is with
the European Space
Agency, who notably landed on
a comet, just a little thing.
We talk about moonshots here
at Google from time to time.
And I always think
the same thing.
I'm like, OK, so you
have a real thing
like this, where
you started it--
you launched it 10 years ago.
And you were working on
for many years before that.
And it's an
astonishing commitment
of time and resources,
energy, and science.
And to have it all work
is incredibly satisfying.
And I saw on your
bio that you're
working on the James Webb,
which, when I look at that
I think, how can
this possibly work?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: We
think that every day.
CHRIS: Because it's such
a complicated device,
and the things we
wanted to do in space
with its reconfigurability
and the thing that
goes over here and the
thing that goes over there--
and I know I'm using lots
of scientific terms here
and I apologize for that.
But is it any less possible
than what you did with Rosetta?
Anyways, the long
and short of it
is, you're not going
to see me talk.
You're here to see Mark talk.
So Dr. McCaughrean, do you want
to come and take to the stage?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN:
Thanks very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
We probably don't need this one.
So thank you, Chris, and thanks
everybody for being here today.
I understand the audience
may be somewhat larger
in the [INAUDIBLE] in the
world beyond this room
as well, which is good to know.
And it's a privilege,
actually, to be
able to come and stand here
after actually 30 years of work
by thousands of people
to get to this point.
Last year was an absolute
blast, an amazing thing
to be involved with.
And I specifically asked
if I could come here.
I'm in the neighborhood,
talking at NASA Ames tomorrow.
And I thought I'd come here
because actually, Google played
a role, as you'll see later on.
It plays such a role in all
of our lives, of course,
but it played a specific role
for us at the end of last year,
which I'll come to later on.
So what I'm going to talk about?
I'm going to talk about the
Rosetta mission in its journey
to this amazing object, which
you see in the bottom here.
You see much more of it called
67P Churyumov-Gerasimenko.
Comets are named for the
people that discover them,
so it's unfortunate that Bob
Smith didn't discover this one.
It's just a long name, but
these two Ukrainian astronomers
discovered it in 1969.
Of course, comets are objects
which are fascinating and have
been fascinating for millennia.
Throughout humankind, people
have looked up in the sky
and seen these
strange visitors that
would come seemingly
out of nowhere,
blaze across the
sky for maybe days,
weeks, in some cases months.
And nobody had any
idea what they were,
where they came from.
They were always thought to be
these messengers from the gods,
perhaps.
This idea that these
things came out of nowhere
unpredictably might be
portents of something bad that
was about to happen.
We see them as
beautiful objects today.
This is actually taken from
the platform of the Very Large
Telescope, which is an array
of four eight meter diameter
telescopes in Chile,
where my colleague here
in the front row,
Hunt [INAUDIBLE]
and I have spent many years
using these telescopes to do
astronomy.
This is astronomy
with the naked eye.
You don't need an
eight meter telescope
to see this particular
comet, Comet McNaught.
But as I said, it goes
back thousands of years.
And this is actually from
1066 or just after 1066.
This is the famous
Bayeaux Tapestry,
which was created by the Normans
to commemorate the invasion
of England in 1066.
This is the usually the
point where I point out this
is the last time it happened.
But other people have tried.
And what you see at the top
here is a comet, emblazoned
across the Bayeaux Tapestry.
And in Latin, it says "these
men wonder at the star."
People here are looking
up and they thought
this was a portent of doom.
And of course, for
the English it was.
For King Harold here, it
was a bit of a problem.
For the Normans, it was portent
of good, you could argue.
So, silver linings and all that.
But what we now know
from subsequent analyses
of this particular object and
the fact that in the record
over 1,000 years,
this object appears
to have come back
every 76 years.
So Edmund Halley--
and you'll guess
what the name of
this comet is now--
found that there
was an apparition
on a regular basis of a comet.
And he said, well,
maybe it's the same one.
And it was.
It's Halley's Comet.
It's what we know
as Halley's comet.
And this was actually seen many,
many times throughout history.
This is just one
of the occasions.
The last time that it
came past was 1986.
And of course 1986, we were
deep into the space age.
And it was possible to actually
go there for the first time.
And so the European
Space Agency launched
a mission called Giotto as
part of an international fleet
to go and encounter Halley.
Now Halley lives out
deep in the solar system,
way out beyond
the giant planets.
And it comes in every
76 years, accelerates
towards the inner solar
system, goes extremely fast
through the middle,
and back out again.
And so what we could do, what we
were capable of doing in 1986,
was effectively do what
anybody in this room--
and I can say that with
absolute certainty--
anybody in this room
would have to do this.
If you wanted to have a
conversation with Usain Bolt
when he was running
the 100 meters,
none of you in this room would
be able to run as fast as him,
right?
So the only way you
could do it is actually
stand out in front of
him as he sprinted past.
And you'd have maybe a couple
of milliseconds of conversation.
You could do that.
You could just direct
yourself to be in his path
as long as you
avoid hitting him.
And that's what we did
with Giotto in 1986.
As Halley swung through
the inner solar system,
we were able to get Giotto
to fly by at 68 kilometers
a second.
And we had just minutes
of that encounter,
the first time that a
comet was seen close up,
the comet nucleus.
And unfortunately, it's
a bit light in the room
so you can't quite see
very well what's here.
But this is the nucleus
of comet Halley,
about 15 kilometers across.
And what you see, and what
was an interesting discovery
at that point is that comets
are actually very dark objects.
We think of comets as being
composed of ice and dust
and therefore the phrase is
often used "dirty snowballs."
And so you'd expect it
to be highly reflective.
Turns out they're not.
They're incredibly dark.
And the surface
here is a mixture
of dust, which has been
lifted up from the comet
as the comet heats up when
it gets close to the sun.
Some of that dust falls
back down onto the surface
and slowly, you get
snowdrifts, if you like,
of dust on the surface.
And also, there's organic
material in comets.
So there's actually complex
carbon-bearing molecules
in comets.
And that makes it dark as well.
Now, we're had a series
of comet missions.
NASA has been to several comets
and one of the most famous
encounters actually did
do what you shouldn't
do, which is it did stand right
in front of Usain Bolt in 2005,
the so-called Deep
Impact Mission.
You can tell what's
coming next, where
it was two spacecraft together.
And the front
spacecraft was actually
set on a direct collision course
with the comet Tempel, Tempel 1
here.
And then the second spacecraft
took pictures of that
as the first one impacted.
And that's the outcome.
Turns out, that's actually
a very small crater.
Another mission has
going back to Tempel 1
since and seen the crater
left in a brief flyby.
It's a pretty small crater,
but a lot of material
was lifted up.
But why would you
want to do this?
What's the point?
It's not just fireworks.
It's cool, but
what's the reason?
The reason is that
the surface of comets
is because of
these dust covering
and these carbon-bearing
molecules is not really
the primordial material anymore.
It's being processed.
Every time a comet's come
through the inner solar system,
it's being frazzled, fried.
Think of it as a baked Alaska.
The outer surface is not
representative of what's
on the inside.
And by excavating
material from underneath
and analyzing that
brief flash of light
from the material as it's
thrown up, not only locally,
but the Hubble
Space Telescope was
used to take data on this
comet during this impact.
You can try to understand
what the comet's made
of on the inside.
And why is that relevant?
Well, it's because comets
are leftover material
from the birth of our solar
system 4.6 billion years ago.
We have this kind
of overview here
of the cycle of life
of stars and planets,
which starts with very
high mass stars generating
the heavy elements in their
course through nuclear fusion,
through supernovae returning on
winds, returning that material
to the interstellar medium.
That kind of mills around in a
galaxy for millions or hundreds
of millions of years
but then slowly
gets reincorporated into dust
clouds, which can then collapse
down to form new stars.
Those stars form
in swirling disks.
And around those stars
you have protoplanets.
They form as well.
You get planets like us.
But you still get lot
of leftover material--
the asteroids and the comets
and lots of small dust particles
as well, leftover stuff.
And that's important, because
some of that leftover stuff
may have played a key role
in us on this planet today.
One of the models for
the way the Earth formed
is that it was extremely hot
when it was young, and so hot
on the surface it
couldn't retain any water.
So one of the big
questions is, where
does the water come
from that we drink
and that we're made of, and
all the water on the planet?
If it wasn't on the surface
shortly after the birth
of the solar system,
was it delivered
from somewhere else later on?
And comets could be a very
important vector for that,
because they lock up ice and
dust in the outer solar system.
And those objects and then come
into the inner solar system
through perturbations and
impact on the planets.
You need about
100 million comets
to get the water we
have on the Earth.
That sounds like
a lot of impacts.
But over half a billion years
in the early solar system,
that's not so often.
There were lots
of comets around.
So investigating comets
to try to understand
whether the water in comets
is the same as the water we
have on the Earth is a
clue to our own origins
in terms of water.
But more than that,
the complex molecules
which are in comets
also, we know
that comets contain
amino acids, for example.
Interstellar space is rich
in carbon-bearing molecules.
And maybe-- again, because it
was hot when it was young--
maybe the comets brought that
organic material to the Earth.
Not life, but organic
material, which could then
be the building blocks of life.
So we could, in some ways,
literally be comet stuff.
You've heard from Carl Sagan
that we're star stuff, yes.
But later in the circuit,
we could actually
be comet stuff as well.
And so by going to a comet and
investigating it in detail, not
just a brief flyby,
we may learn much more
about our own origins.
So I'm going to stop briefly
here and show you a five minute
film which we put together
last year from a completely
different perspective,
to try to open up
this story about our own
origins, where we came from,
the role that comets
might have played.
And we did it-- we wanted
to reach the general public,
so we did it through the
medium of a science fiction
film, which was novel.
NASA called us up afterwards
and said, how the hell
did you do that?
We want to do that too.
Which doesn't
often happen to us.
It usually goes the
other way around.
So I'll show it to you.
And it's something
which is a word which
I'm sure this company and
many other people I speak to
are well aware of.
The film is called "Ambition."
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[EXPLOSION]
-Enough.
Walk with me.
Perhaps we should
find you something
a little last challenging.
-I don't understand.
I've planned everything.
Let me do it again.
-Once upon a time--
-Really.
-This is a good one, I promise.
What is the key
to life on Earth?
-Water.
For a long time,
the origins of water
and indeed life
on our home planet
remained an absolute mystery.
So we began searching
for answers beyond Earth.
Where could all this
water have come from?
In time, we turned to comets.
One trillion celestial balls of
ice, dust, complex molecules,
left over from the birth
of our solar system,
once thought of as messengers
of doom and destruction,
and yet so
enchanting, if we were
to catch one, a
staggeringly ambitious plan.
-Are you talking about
the Rosetta mission?
-Throw me the probe.
We harnessed whole
planets and their gravity
to chase down the comet.
So many things could have gone
wrong-- the failure at launch,
an error in the calculations,
collisions-- so many unknowns.
With the technology
we had back then, we
may as well have been shooting
from a slingshot And tell me,
what was it all for?
-Knowledge.
-Yes, but we also wanted
to show what was possible.
-I know all this
from the archives.
There were bigger
missions after.
-Yes.
It was the first one
to catch a comet.
Ambition, stubbornness--
nothing has changed, We fall.
We pick ourselves up again.
And we adapt.
I was watching you earlier.
You actually did
everything right.
I destroyed your rock.
I needed to see how
you would react.
You're ready.
Reset.
Nicely done.
Let's begin.
[APPLAUSE]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So I'm sure many
of you recognize
Littlefinger from "Game
of Thrones" there,
Aidan Gillen, out there
somewhere a million years
from now, looking back
at our amazing mission.
But of course we had to turn
the science fiction-- which
we made last year--
we had to turn it
30 years ago into science fact.
So at the time of Halley, when
we encountered with Giotto,
we knew that we wanted to do
more than just a brief flyby.
We wanted to get close to a
comet, rendezvous with one,
and land on one
and follow it as it
went around the inner
part of the solar system
to see it evolve, to see how the
material flows from the surface
and get exposure to the
material from underneath.
So in 1985, this mission was
actually started to be planned.
And by 1994, we got to the
point where we're building it.
It took about 10
years to build it.
And just give you
a sense of scale,
Rosetta, its wingspan from
tip to tip, is 32 meters.
That's the size
of an Airbus A320.
It's got the biggest
solar panels ever used
on a spacecraft, because
as you'll see in a moment,
it had to go all the way
out to the orbit of Jupiter.
And out there, the sun
is not very bright.
More importantly, it's cold.
And having big solar panels
to generate enough power
for the spacecraft
to operate, we
had these huge arrays which
you see here folded up.
What you see alongside
in the middle
is the spacecraft itself.
It's about a three
by three meter cube.
It weighs about three tons.
Half of that is propellant.
The rest is all the spacecraft
bus and the electronics
and the instruments, which I'll
talk a little bit later on.
And that's the famous Philae
on the side, Philae the lander.
It's about one
meter by one meter.
People say it's the size
of a washing machine.
I don't have a washing
machine that big in my house.
My boxer shorts would be
clean much quicker if I did.
Just give you a sense
of the scale of this.
And it took from 1994 or
so to be built until 2003.
And we were ready
to launch in 2003.
It was prepared for
an Ariane 5 launch
in Kuru, in French Guiana.
But unfortunately, we
had a failure of one
of the Ariane 5's
just beforehand, not
the Rosetta launch.
And then we had to have
an accident investigation
board, all the usual
stuff that you do.
By the time we were ready to
go a year later, the comet we
we're going to had gone.
We couldn't catch up with it.
So within that one year, we
had to pick a whole new comet
to go to.
And in 2004 in March,
we are ready to go.
And since I work in
the space business,
you can't have a talk
without showing a launch.
So this is the launch
from French Guiana.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So that's what we do
in the space business.
We build incredibly
delicate scientific machines
and then shake the
crap out of them
for eight minutes, which is
why it takes a long time to get
these things fully tested.
There's no going
after them afterwards.
So where were we going?
We were going to this comet,
67P Churyumov-Gerasimenko,
as I said.
Most comets, many comets
are in an elliptical orbit.
67P goes out beyond
the orbit of Jupiter.
It doesn't get super close to
the sun at its closest point.
It gets between the
orbits of Earth and Mars.
But the amount of
solar flux that it
gets by being that
close is hugely more
than it gets out in
the outer solar system.
So it changes its state an
awful lot as it comes in.
But as I said, in 1986 all
we could do with our rockets
was just fly past a comet.
Even now, we don't have
big enough rockets to go
to comets like this directly.
We don't have enough power
to get to one and rendezvous
on this big elliptical orbit.
So we have to cheat.
And the way we do that-- and you
heard it in the Ambition film,
is we harness the
gravity of the planets.
We actually use flybys-- sorry.
What we did was actually come
back to the Earth one year
later and use the Earth's
gravitational energy, its force
to slingshot us faster and
onto a more elliptical orbit.
We flew by Earth three times.
And we actually
encountered Mars once.
This actually slowed
us down a bit,
but we used that to get us
onto a more eccentric orbit.
And since we were
doing all of this,
we flew through the
asteroid belt twice.
And while you're passing, you
might as well make a visit.
And we visited two asteroids
on the way through as well.
So this asteroid Steins in 2008.
And you'll see when
we get further out,
we go to asteroid Lutetia.
That's the comet going through.
The comet's on a six
and a half year orbit.
We didn't miss it.
We just knew we had to
wait for next time around.
So it was probably a bit
galling to be on the spacecraft
going, next time, next time.
And so you see that we'll
encounter Lutetia here
in 20-- a little
bit before that.
And then we went into this thing
called deep space hibernation.
Even though we have
these huge solar panels,
we had enough power
to run the spacecraft,
but not if we had a problem.
When we have problems
on spacecraft,
there's a lot of power used in
what's called safe mode to boot
everything back up again.
And so what we actually
did was go into hibernation
for 2 and 1/2 years.
We shut the whole system
down apart from some heaters
to keep the fuel lines
from freezing over.
We turned off all the
stabilization systems.
And the only way
then we could keep
the spacecraft pointed at
the sun in a stable way
was by spinning it.
So we spun it up
into a lazy spin.
But the high gain
antenna at that point
was no longer pointing at Earth.
It's pointing all over the
place as it spins around.
So we had no way of directly
talking to the spacecraft
anymore.
The engineers hated this,
as you can imagine--
turning your billion euro
asset off out in space
and waiting for-- the one
thing that was powered up
was an alarm clock.
And that alarm
clock was powered up
for 2 and 1/2 years later for
January, 2014 January the 20th.
And we had to hope
that that was going
to go off so that we could
get to where we are here
at the end of last
year for rendezvous.
And you can see, we're trying
to rendezvous quite far
out in the solar system.
We want to rendezvous while
the comet's not active,
far from the sun.
We want to get down to
landing before it gets active.
But we can't do it too soon,
because we need enough power
to power the spacecraft up.
So we had this three
month window or so
where we arrived and then had
to do the landing-- incredibly,
incredibly fast.
Normally, you prepare for
landings years in advance.
You send another probe.
You take pictures.
You do analyses.
We had none of that luxury.
We had to do it in
three months flat.
On the way past, one of
my favorite pictures--
this is Antarctica
on a flyby, skimming
across the Earth's surface
or the above the atmosphere.
We flew past Mars.
And even though it wasn't yet
probably in the Oxford English
Dictionary, we took a
selfie, because you do.
I'm not really sure
this is quite a selfie,
because this is actually
Philae has an array of seven
cameras around the outside.
And it took a picture of
Rosetta, the spacecraft here
and the solar panel.
And I suppose you
call this photobombing
by Mars in the background.
So it was a very savvy mission
even before we launched it.
And here's our encounter
with Lutetia in 2010.
And it's kind of a
bit jerky because we
took lots of pictures.
And then we take fewer
pictures until we encounter.
And it looks like
we got pretty close.
Actually, we were 3,000
kilometers away at the time.
So we have a good telephoto
lens, let's put it that way.
So this was a big object more
than 100 kilometers in size.
So we get to-- after that, we
turn this the spacecraft off,
spin it up, and pray.
And here we are
January the 20th.
We had a sweepstakes this day
in the control room in Germany,
in Darmstadt.
And these are the
guys, flight directors,
who know this system
inside out, completely.
And they had a sweepstakes and
it was 20 people in the room,
20 times.
What minute is it
going to wake up on?
So when we got past
the first minute,
people went, yay, you lost.
Never mind, I get the money.
And you go for
the second person.
Hey, you lost.
Person number 20, oh dear.
It hadn't woken up.
We were 18 minutes late.
And we know why
now in retrospect.
There was a reboot on board.
Perfectly feasible after that
length of time, but unsuspected
that it would happen.
And we finally got the
signals through both Goldstone
and through camera.
And we get the signals
here, which you can see.
That says we have
a carrier signal.
And predictably, we had
some great enthusiasm.
Because of course,
without this moment,
without the
spacecraft waking up,
we had nothing, after
10 years of flight.
There was no mission at all.
So this was an enormous
moment for these guys
who worked for many years.
I'll let you a little
secret as well.
On the day, we immediately
had the spacecraft tweet.
And for all the geeks
in the audience, hello,
world-- of course, exactly
what you would tweet, right?
So we built Twitter
into Rosetta years
before Twitter even existed.
Actually, this is Emily.
She's our social media guru
sitting in the front row here.
And she tweeted.
So social media's actually
been a very important part
of the mission for us.
And we've had a lot of feedback.
So it was hello, world on
that day, in 20 languages.
We soon knew after that that we
were heading towards a comet.
You can see pictures
taken from the spacecraft.
You can see the tail
developing of the comet here.
This is actually bit of a worry,
because this phase, as I said,
we were further out
in the solar system.
We didn't expect
activity at this point.
We don't want activity
at this point,
because we don't want to
be next to an active comet
when we're trying to
learn how to land on it.
Fortunately, this activity
died away shortly afterwards.
But that's the
problem with comets.
They're dynamic, living objects.
It's not a dead body.
And so learning to actually
fly up next to this object
and maneuver around it
whilst it's changing
has been a huge challenge.
But beyond that, it
was even challenging
when we first got there.
Because if I remind
you, this is Tempel 1.
This is the object-- this is
a kind of prototypical comet
that we thought we were flying
to-- potato-shaped, fairly
smooth, lots of smooth
places to land on.
And this is what the scientists
were actually planning for.
Now, when we started to get
just barely resolved images
of the comet, we began to
see a jittering around.
And you could decode little
bit about the shape from this.
But of course, rapidly we
got closer and we saw this.
And this was something
which led to the moniker
"the rubber duck,"
which everybody said.
It was at this point-- as
you can see a rotating image
of this thing, that the
engineers were just "Oh,God."
Because we actually have to
fly next to this thing and land
on it?
The scientists thought this
was fantastic, of course,
because we may actually have
two comets for the price of one.
How do you get
this binary object?
Is it two comets, different
origins, different compositions
which may have fused by a
collision at some point?
We still don't know that.
We don't believe that's
the case anymore,
but again engineers,
scientists, the usual tension.
And when we got close up on
August 6th in rendezvous,
it got even more, well,
engineers and scientists.
Because this is the object
we rendezvoused with.
And it's just an astonishingly
complicated object.
It's four kilometers across.
We now know the
mass of this object.
It's 10 billion tons.
And you can quickly
do the math there.
You realize this object actually
has density half that of water.
It's much, much less dense
than a regular iceberg.
It would sit half the
way up in the water
if you could sit it in a lake.
But it's the surface structures
which have everybody amazed,
because this comet
actually has not
been in the inner solar
system for very many years.
It was discovered in 1969.
But we can track
back its trajectory.
We knew that in 1959, it had
an encounter with Jupiter,
which moved it closer in.
Before that, it used
to live further out
in the solar system.
So how come it's so eroded,
so completely covered in all
these craters and boulders?
And one thing you need to
know about the craters, these
are not impact craters.
This object's barely being
hit by anything else.
Those kind of
collisions don't happen
like they do in the asteroid
belt in "Star Wars,"
I'm afraid.
Things are far apart.
Collisions don't really happen
like that between small bodies.
These craters here
are actually--
the water and the CO2,
as it gets heated up
from the ice phase, it
sublimes into the gas phase
from underneath and blows
craters out from underneath.
These are the kinds
of things we're
going to be seeing in
the next few months
as these craters start erupting.
This only happens when
you're close to the sun, when
there's enough energy and you
get above the phase transition.
So again, scientists
absolutely thrilled by this.
And the engineers looked
and thought, well,
the precision of our
lander, the ability
to deposit our object on
the surface-- it's not
guided to the surface.
It's thrown like a dart.
We going to land within
a one kilometer circle.
Show me somewhere flat over
And just to give
you a sense of scale
and just to illustrate the
glory that Google has brought
to all of us in the world
is, you want anything
on the internet now,
you Google something.
I wanted a four
kilometer tall object.
This is Mt.
Blanc, just over
four kilometers,
as seen from 100 kilometers,
which is the distance
we rendezvoused at.
This lady is sitting here in
the Swiss Jura exactly 100
kilometers away, looking at Mt.
Blanc.
And just for scale,
that's what it
would look like if we put
the comet into the picture.
So it was called the
Klingon ship at some point.
You can kind of see
bird of prey look here.
And as we got
closer, of course, we
began to see these
astonishing structures here--
cliff faces, areas that look
like dunes, big boulders.
But remember, none
of this is rock.
None of this is
classical geology at all.
It's much lighter.
There's dust there.
There are small particles.
But these boulders are
not great big rocks.
They're matrix material
of ice and dust.
And the other thing
to keep in mind
is all the other
physical effects
on the Earth doesn't
really make a lot of sense.
There's no atmosphere.
There's no weathering.
There's no rivers in that way.
And one of the most
fundamental things
is when you look at an object
like this, where is down?
That boulder there-- where's the
down vector for that boulder?
And of course, it's local.
The down vector is
local everywhere
you are in an irregular object.
You can try to pick
out the area which
has the biggest mass underneath
you and say that's down,
but you don't know the
density profile well enough.
This object is actually
very porous on the inside.
Not porous in the sense
that there's huge caves,
we don't think.
But to get to the
density we measure,
it's a very loose structure.
Gravity is not
really acting on it
in the way you would think of
making a compactified object.
So when you look
around and you try
to work out how things
eroded to get where they are,
to be very careful.
You also have to remember
that the comet's rotating
every 12 and 1/2 hours.
And that centrifugal
force changes things
completely as well.
And I'll show you
that in a moment.
Where you think the gravity
would be highest, it isn't.
And so there are areas
like this as well,
these sort of planes of material
with kind of scalloping here.
How did these boulders,
for example, get there?
You could think the other
boulders might have fallen off
cliffs and somehow slowly
rolled down cliffs and landed
in the valley.
But how did these get here?
Did they actually
fall from somewhere,
or they actually
material underneath,
which have been eroded out as
the comet's being eroded away
over these thousands of years
that it's been relatively
close to the sun, are you
exposing pieces of the matrix
underneath?
This one is christened Cheops
for its pyramid-type structure.
It's about 20 meters high.
And I thought, well, you want
to put this to scale, right?
Everybody wants it to scale.
So I made this image
and instantly realized
that we couldn't release it
from the European Space Agency,
because you could
imagine what would happen
if we did, thanks to you guys.
Every lunatic in the world--
sorry, but anybody watching--
would say hey, look.
Told you, told you.
Conspiracy Face on Mars.
So this was released
through a back door.
It didn't have ESA's tag on it.
I can now say that
I did make it,
but it's also
illustrating the fact
that we have this
Egyptian naming theme.
Rosetta, the mission,
of course refers
to the Rosetta Stone, which
is the way of decoding
Egyptian hieroglyphics.
And the naming scheme for
the geological areas all
actually have the names
of Egyptian deities here.
And this is what the scientists,
of course, are doing now
is trying to characterize
the various areas,
try to understand how
they would have evolved.
Because not all these areas
see the same amount of sunlight
all the time.
Going to hand around a
model of the comet here.
This side area really
hasn't seen much sunlight
at all in the last
six years or so.
But as it moves
towards the sun, it's
going to be seeing
more sunlight.
So the place where you
actually get more light,
you get more activity,
you get more sculpting.
So we're trying to
actually try to work out
how these areas correspond
to solar illumination,
and other things.
This is an honesty test.
If I don't get it
back at the end,
I'll be able to
dine out on saying
that it got lost at Google.
And of course, one
of the other pictures
which is being shown
many times-- again,
to give a sense of scale, which
we like a lot, is this one.
But I'll leave that one
best unspoken perhaps.
It's not snow, unfortunately.
And we've put a lot of our
pictures in the public domain.
We release our images from
our navigation cameras
are released through
Creative Commons.
We encourage people to go
and do things with them.
And in fact, there's
many, many creative people
out there in the world,
many in this room as well.
And this is just
one thing that's
being done by one of our
friends, Matthias Malmo,
making 3D models, actually.
He works in the video industry,
knows how to do this stuff.
Took the images and
created shape models.
We're doing this
scientifically as well.
But I have to say,
sometimes these guys
are better than we are
at it, for good reasons.
They do this as
their daily life.
But we didn't just go there, of
course, just to take pictures.
We went there to do science.
So I'll just give
you a brief rundown
of the kinds of
scientific instruments
we have on Rosetta
itself, which carries
most of the scientific
instrumentation.
We have cameras which span
from the millimeter end,
where you can actually
see beneath the surface
of the comet, all
the way out to the UV
through the infrared and the
optical, taking lots of images.
We measure-- as the
material flows past Rosetta,
we measure the gas and the
dust through mass spectroscopy,
see what it's actually made of.
We know, for example,
that the comet stinks.
It's got a lot of
organic molecules.
It's got hydrogen
sulfide, hydrogen cyanide.
It's characterized
as being a horse
barn with the lovely
addition of cyanide.
So we've been thinking of making
a perfume, bottle of perfume
actually.
I just don't think it
will go down very well,
but-- smelling like
a comet, it stinks.
It's not nice.
We also capture individual
particles of dust.
We measure them with atomic
force microscopes on board
and then we zap them with little
high powered LED or ion guns,
rather, and then see what
material comes off it
so we can analyze
what it's made of.
There's a plasma
associated with this comet.
Even though it's very cold, well
below freezing point of water,
there is a plasma
wrapped around it.
Mostly it's the solar wind
which is wrapped around it.
And Philae, the lander
itself, is much smaller,
has quite a complement of
scientific instruments as well.
So lots of images-- you'll
see some of those as we
go down to the surface and
also microscopy of the surface.
We analyze the
material in situ now.
We try to tie together in
the one location-- or is
it turns out, the
multiple locations
we landed-- the
material we see there
with what we can see from
orbit around the comet.
So we can try to tie
that together so we
can get a more global picture.
And we had a drill on board to
actually go down 25 centimeters
below the surface and pull
material out and put it
into a laboratory on board.
Interesting
experiment is actually
linking the two spacecraft
together through, effectively,
FM frequency radio
waves and doing
tomography of the interior
of the comet, which
is kind of cool.
And then the last thing we
do is beam data back home--
sensible thing to do.
But we can actually measure
the speed of the spacecraft
to precision of roughly
a tenth of a millimeter
per second at that distance,
which allows us then to measure
the gravity and the higher
order moments of gravity,
what the internal
density structure is.
One of the most basic things
about the comet people
always ask, why is it you
show all these pictures which
are snowy white, when
you tell us it's dark,
and the one I'm
carrying around is dark?
Well of course, we just
crank the contrast up
so you can see anything.
But to give you a
sense, Enceladus
is one of the moons of Saturn.
It's coated in fresh
ice from the water
which comes out through the
stripes of the bottom there.
Effectively reflects 100% of
the light that falls on it.
The Earth is relatively
dark, only reflects about 30%
of the light that falls on.
The moon, which we
think of as being white,
only reflect 12% of
sunlight that falls on it.
It's a very dark
object in reality.
67P, I promise you, is there.
Reflects about 6% of the
light that falls on it.
It's just being a cold cellar.
It's incredibly dark.
People also ask,
why is that you only
show black and white pictures?
Why won't you show a color one?
Well, this is the
right brightness
and I'm going to turn the
brightness up and turn
the color up, because
it is that color.
It is just incredibly
dark and dusty.
There's very little color
differentiation there,
as the human eye would see.
But we have filters
on our cameras
which can enhance
the colors a bit.
And in fact, you do see
some color differences.
And you can see here the
head part of the comet here
compared to the neck,
you'll see as I scroll down,
a bluer color in the neck.
And we believe that that's
because the dust coating there
in that neck region's
actually thinner
and we're seeing the
ice coming through.
It's more exposed there.
Because ice, of course,
we do expect to see ice.
At the moment, we're
seeing a very dusty object,
but that dust will be blown
away in the next few months,
because we have the whole
fresh phase of heating.
And then as we move
back away from the sun,
some of the dust
in the atmosphere
will fall back onto the
surface and coat it again.
Actually, that's what
kills comets in the end.
After thousands and
thousands of years,
you build up enough
dust on the surface.
You don't blow it away
each time, all of it.
You get an insulating layer.
You can't even heat
the ice anymore.
So we know that in
our solar system,
there are many dormant
comets, former comets.
Comets don't live forever.
So I talked to you about
the surface gravity
and about centrifugal force.
We've measured that.
Here's the effective
gravitational potential.
You would think the
gravitational force would
be strongest when
you're standing
over the biggest piece of mass.
But what we see here is
because of the spinning,
the gravitational potential
is actually lowest
on the two ends of the comet.
And you can also see that the
local slope of the surface--
let me finish this thought--
the local slope changes a lot
relative to the
gravitational potential.
You can see, it can be
up to 60 degrees off.
So sort of metaphorically,
if you're walking around,
suddenly gravity moves
off by 30 degrees.
Depends on what's
under the surface.
It depends where you are.
AUDIENCE: Where's the
rotation axis here?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN:
The rotation axis
is more or less
through the neck.
So if you were to
take the comet,
stick a pin through
the neck, it's
the two ends are spinning
up at the highest speed.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So the dust, it seems
like if it was getting dormant,
wouldn't you still have some
of the dust blowing off?
I'm surprised that you
would have more and more
accumulate over time.
MARK MCCAUGHREAN:
The question was,
why is it that we don't blow
the dust away every time?
Why do we get an
accumulating layer?
Well, it's just the physics
of the gas and the dust
and how they couple.
The gas can flow
away very readily.
It flows away at high speed.
The dust is coupled to
the gas at the beginning,
but drag forces act on it and
it gets slowed down and forced
back to the surface.
So a fraction of the dust
ends up back on the surface
every time.
And that is particularly bad
when the velocities of the gas
escaping a low, which happens
when you're furthest away
from the sun.
So we get that coating.
We know that we're actually
the comet dust we're
measuring today is old dust
from last time around the sun,
we believe.
We're going to be seeing
different kind of dust
coming fresh from
the surface now.
So just to give you a sense
of scale about the gravity,
this is one of my
favorite pictures,
just showing kind of the
sweeping vista on the comet.
This cliff here, this cliff
face is 100 meters high from top
to bottom.
So I'm sure half of you in
the room immediately thinking,
base jumping, right?
It would be the most boring
base jump in the world.
Parachute wouldn't work,
because there's no atmosphere.
But you wouldn't
need one, because it
would take you 20 minutes to
get from the top to the bottom.
And you would arrive
at the velocity
of 0.2 meters per second at
the bottom, 20 centimeters
a second.
You'd just walk off the bottom.
But actually, you'd have
to be careful, because you
know base jumping is?
To clear any obstructions,
you stand at the top--
as if I've done it--
and you jump up and out.
But if you jumped too
high, for too hard,
you will go to escape velocity.
So I'm going to get you
to demonstrate what escape
velocity of the comet is.
If you all stand up, you're all
going to jump off the comet.
So if you all stand up,
you have to jump that high.
And if you can jump that
high, 4 centimeters,
you will have reached
0.9 meters a second.
That's escape velocity for 67P.
So, three, two, one, jump.
Good.
Now of course, I've
talked about this comet,
its gravity, its structures.
And people are
interested in that.
But of course, one of the
great things is, it's changing.
We seeing activity.
We're seeing material
begin to flow away as we
come in closer to the sun.
And in fact, we look in
some of these sublimation
pits, these craters.
If we crank up the contrast, we
see stuff beginning to come out
of the craters themselves,
the material flowing away.
This is what we would expect.
And as we're getting
close to the sun now,
we're seeing more and
more of this activity.
Here are some of
the dust particles
which we're gathering.
They tend to be very clumpy,
fractal structures which
as soon as we catch
them, they fall apart.
They're not strong
at all, structurally.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
With central low gravity,
how do you [INAUDIBLE]?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN:
It can be in orbit.
When we arrived
at 100 kilometers,
we actually got to the point.
We don't know how massive
the comet is at that point.
So we don't know how
to go into orbit.
You need to know that, right?
That's a starting point.
So we flew in triangles
in front, power triangles.
We would cruise, then power,
go this way, go that way,
and move closer until
we started seeing
bending in the trajectories.
And that would tell
us what the mass was.
So when we get down to
30 kilometers or so,
this is a several week orbit.
But it's an orbit, so we were
actually in orbit for a while.
We're standing back now, because
the comet's getting active.
So we're back out at
100 kilometers again.
We're not in orbit there.
We're flying trajectories.
But down at 30
kilometers and below,
we consider ourselves
to be in orbit.
So its weak, but gravity
still works on those scales.
We've told you that the
plasma, the interaction
between the comet and
the solar wind-- this
is a very technical graph,
but it's much easier
if you listen to it.
[RATTLING SOUND]
So this is speeded up, to put
it into audible frequencies.
What you're actually hearing
is the rotation of the comet,
modulating the interaction
of the solar wind
as it flows past.
So, the sound of a
comet spinning in space.
Cool, right?
Now, here's the kicker.
I showed you the film
"Ambition" at the beginning
and I talked about the fact
we were trying to go and see
whether the water on this comet
was the same as the water we're
made of.
The way you would do
that is to measure
the deuterium to hydrogen
ratio, the isotope of hydrogen.
Because on Earth,
it's one number.
It's always the same,
everywhere-- the amount
of deuterium in water.
What we know from
other comets is
it tends to be
high on the comets,
whereas asteroids
are pretty good.
Asteroids are quite Earthlike.
A comet was seen and
measured in 2012,
which would seem to have exactly
the same ratio as the Earth.
And it's from the
same family as 67P.
So we thought, well,
maybe these families
of comets at this
distance from the sun,
maybe they have the
right kind of water.
Unfortunately, 67P has the
worst ratio ever mentioned--
very high.
And so of course we already
know that this comet
didn't bring the Earth's
water, by definition, right?
But what it opens up
now is this question
of trying to create a
recipe for making the cake.
We know the Earth is
being hit by comets.
We know the Earth
gets hit by asteroids.
We know that there are all
these objects out there.
Some are closer to the sun.
Some are further away.
But we're trying to build
up the picture of how many
of these versus
how many of those
could end up with the right
kind of water that we have.
You see, there are
very few objects
at all that have
water with a low d
to h ratio than the Earth.
So since we do get
hit by some of these,
how do you get a lower
one on the Earth?
And there are other
models for how
the Earth's water came
as well, and other people
will comment on that.
We can ask some
questions about that.
Maybe it didn't get delivered
from the outside at all.
Maybe it was stored
up on the Earth,
even when it was very hot.
One of the more fascinating
things about the structure
of the comet is this.
You can see these lumps.
They were originally called
dinosaur eggs, goosebumps.
They about a meter
or two across.
And we see internal
structure-- not
on the surface, which is being
processed-- but in the pits.
We see this texture.
And the question is,
are these actually
the primordial structures,
the objects which
formed at the beginning
of the solar system
and they actually came
together, agglomerated
and formed the bigger
objects called comets.
Are these the building
blocks of comets
we're actually seeing inside?
We may, we may get lucky.
And we may see it
much more clearly,
because 67P has a 500-meter long
crack running through the neck,
which you can see here.
We know comets fall apart.
We see it all the time.
67P could fall apart
this time around the sun.
The engineers would
hate that, because they
have to fly around two
objects simultaneously.
We would love it,
because then we
could see the primordial
material on the inside
before it gets
affected by the sun.
There's no guarantee
it'll happen this time.
It'll happen in
the future someday.
This object's bound
to fall apart.
But it would be very cool.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MCCAUGHREAN:
Well, thank you.
So, last bit of the talk.
Let me talk a bit
about the landing.
OK So here's another
selfie again.
This is real photobombing now.
A comet in the background
of your selfie-- I
mean, you can't do
better than that, right?
So we arrived in
August and we knew
that we had to plan to get
down to the surface by November
before the comet got too active.
And so we started
identifying landing sites.
None of them were going
to be fully clear.
We started with 10 A through
J. We whittled it down to five.
And you can see in
each case, the square
here is one kilometer.
So this is the
typical accuracy we
thought we would have when we
threw our dart at the comet.
Because we don't know
the gravity that well.
And the gravity's non-uniform.
So landing in a certain
place is not so easy.
We ended up taking site J
as the best of all worlds.
We also had to place that
had sunlight and satisfied
other constraints.
But you can see,
there are cliffs
and there are structures here.
It was not guaranteed
at all that when
we hit the surface here,
that we would be safe.
And C was the backup over there.
And a bit more detail, this
is the landing site, now as
an error circle one kilometer.
We aim to land there.
And the way to think
about it, in fact,
is like darts, to scale.
If you stood in front
of a normal dartboard,
the dartboard, the distance
of, called in English the oche,
is exactly the
size of the comet--
it's the same ratio-- the
distance we threw from,
20 kilometers, and the
size of the object.
As you'll see in a moment,
we landed in the 25.
We were 120 meters away from
the nominal touchdown point--
amazing.
I mean, the guys that drive
this spacecraft deserve
huge credit to go 10
years through space
and then throw the dart.
They didn't get a bullseye,
so they shouldn't cocky.
But they were pretty close.
So how do you do this?
Well, if you're an astronaut,
it's really easy, right?
You do this.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[INAUDIBLE]
Apparently it's translating
really slow but at least
[INAUDIBLE].
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So this is Alex,
guest on the ISS,
who did a demo, an
educational demo for us.
He spent hours doing
this, throwing an earplug
at a piece of Velcro
on a rotating sphere.
It looks good in the video.
He got it.
But lots of one where he
pinged off in-- it's all good.
In reality, it was
much complicated
than that, of course.
We worked our way down
into a 10 kilometer orbit,
took high res pictures.
We then had to work our
way back out to get up
on to this trajectory.
Then when we dropped
down from 20 kilometers,
more or less straight
towards the nucleus,
we dropped Philae off,
pushed it out of the back
at 18 centimeters a second,
and then Rosetta pulled up so
that it could
maintain radio contact
throughout the entire seven
hour descent onto the surface--
seven, eight hours descent.
So we actually just-- it was
Isaac Newton at that point.
It was all down to
the laws of gravity.
No guiding at all.
We had a gyro on board,
a big stabilization wheel
to make sure we
maintained orientation.
And it looked roughly like this.
So music here-- composed for
us by Vangelis, of all people--
nice original music.
Of course, the comet's
rotating 12 and 1/2 hours.
And it takes eight hours
to get to the surface.
So you're not
aiming at the point.
You don't even see
it when you throw.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now, that was the plan.
The plan being, of course,
you're arriving at 1 meter
a second.
It's walking pace.
It's a 100 kilo object.
It's low gravity, but
inertia is a killer, right?
We hit hard, relatively.
Try it, somebody
100 kilos, let them
walk into you at walking pace.
You'll feel it.
And of course, the danger
was that we would bounce.
So we had ice
screws in the feet.
We had harpoons underneath.
We'll get to that in a moment.
So this is what it
looked like in reality.
This is the farewell shot.
This is Philae taking
a picture of Rosetta
with a solar panel
is it backs away.
And this is the equivalent,
this is Rosetta taking pictures
of Philae as it descends
away down to the surface,
getting more and more pixelized
as it gets further away,
of course.
We even see it moving across
the surface of the comet.
Series of pictures here taken
a few minutes apart-- you
can see Philae in each case,
the little legs descending
above the surface.
It's actually descending
pretty much vertically.
But because Rosetta's moving
and the comet's rotating,
it doesn't look like that.
But it's more or less going
straight down vertically.
It's a picture taken
from three kilometers
as the lander's
approaching the surface.
And here are the pictures
taken at the surface,
from about 40 meters
down to about 10.
You can see the lander leg here.
So that's from about 10 meters.
And to give you a sense of
scale, this is from Philae.
But if I put Philae in the
shot and put it on the surface,
this is what Philae
would look like.
So it's still pretty
rough at that scale.
It's not as smooth as we
would like to have to been
and this is accurately
where we landed.
This is the place we landed.
And in fact, that boulder there
could be part of the reason--
when we actually did
bounce, as you know,
we didn't bounce vertically.
We went off at an angle.
And it could be in part
because of hitting that rock.
And so this is where
we touched down.
You can see the
three feet, there.
So we have pictures from orbit.
I can now play you
the sound of landing
through transducers on the legs.
And that's in real time.
That's what landing was.
We hit down.
We went through about
25 centimeters of dust,
which is what you see
these pools kicked up.
And we hit a very rigid surface.
Even though, again, we know
that's a very low density
object, that doesn't stop
it being pretty hard.
Think of balsa
wood or something.
Can be very light, but
it can be fairly strong.
What we then saw all
shortly afterwards
was this, from our
navigation cameras.
We see a dark patch there.
That's a shadow of the
dust kicked up by Philae
being cast on the surface.
And then we see Philae
here and Philae's shadow.
So we see Philae departing in
the navigation camera images.
And in the high res pictures,
this is the touchdown point.
And there's Philae, on its way.
Philae flew for a
further two hours,
and very luckily clipped
a cliff on its way.
Because if it hadn't
clipped that cliff,
it would have gone back
out into space again.
So what we now know
we've reconstructed,
is it for roughly an hour,
hit the edge of a cliff here.
During this phase-- I told
you it had a big stabilization
wheel internally.
That kept it level as it
came down to the surface.
That was turned off as soon
as we made first contact.
But as we then flew again,
the angular momentum
transferred into the
lander and the lander
started rotating, but level.
So the lander started rotating.
When it hit the cliff,
it started tumbling.
We never lost radio contact
with the lander throughout,
though, which was amazing.
And then an hour later, we
end up somewhere over here
on the edge.
This is landing site B, by
the way, which we chose.
We didn't want to
land in, so we've just
flew over it instead.
We ended up here.
We bounced one more time,
flew up a little bit
and then a few minutes later
came down a few meters away.
And here are the
heights that we got to.
We got about 100 meters,
150 meters above the surface
during this flight.
If we hadn't hit this
cliff-- the problem is,
this is actually
stretched out linearly.
The comet itself is curved.
We possibly would have
gone off into space there.
But we did land, and we
landed in this place,
up against a wall.
We think we're tilted
up against this wall.
It's relatively shadowed.
So we don't actually have
enough power on the lander
to keep it going.
What we wanted was to
land in a sunny location
where we'd have enough
power to keep the lander,
after its primary battery,
60 hours, ran out,
the rechargeable batteries
would kick in and keep us going.
We didn't have enough
sunlight in this location
at this time to power
the secondary battery.
So we went into
hibernation after 60 hours.
The traditional question is,
why don't you use nuclear power
on your spacecraft?
Because we're Europeans.
But what's very
fascinating about this is,
if you want to have a silver
lining, when we first landed,
we land on a pretty boring place
covered in dust, because that's
the safest place we could land.
The scientists
didn't really-- they
knew they had to land there,
but they didn't want to.
They wanted to land up next
to some primordial material.
And that's where we ended
up, right next to a cliff
made out of ice and dust matrix.
AUDIENCE: This was all planned.
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: Of
course, absolutely.
I only wish.
We would have had a lot more
sleep in the last six months
or.
So of course, at the time,
without even touching down
on the comet was a
colossal success.
Nobody had ever done this--
first soft touchdown.
At this moment, this
photograph, the guys
who were about
here in the picture
already knew we were flying.
These guys didn't.
So, big media success.
It was a huge day,
the 12th of November--
absolutely astonishing.
The world really got into this.
And we had front
covers of newspapers
absolutely everywhere.
It was just astonishing.
It became one of those things
where people were talking
about the fact
people were talking
about the fact people were
talking about it happening.
And it just--
absolutely amazing.
So in fact, yes, we
certainly didn't plan it.
But if you want to have the
maximum possible engagement
from the public, build in a
bit of jeopardy in your mission
and make things
not work properly.
And we got to the end
of the year, of course.
And this is one
of the reasons I'm
very happy to be here today.
We had a Google
Doodle on the 12th.
And then without us
knowing about it,
on the end of the year.
This one I found-- I'm not sure
I should really say this here,
but just an interesting lesson
about a risk-averse company,
let's put it that way.
We knew that this
Google Doodle was
being made, the landing one.
And on the 12th of
November, I looked.
I went on Google, and it
wasn't there-- come on.
So I sent an email saying,
you know it's today, right?
To which the reply was, yes,
but we're not posting it
until you land successfully.
So, good enough, I think, right?
Front cover of
"Science" magazine.
All these letters
going out of the UK
had this "Congratulations to
the European Space Agency."
And as a Brit, the Brits saying
anything positive about Europe
is not very common, so
thank you very much.
And the flight director,
Andrea [INAUDIBLE] one
of the key people
in the year here.
This down here is actually
the Hollywood award,
Hollywood nomination
for the "Ambition" film.
So our friends from Poland
who made the film for us
had a nice evening
out in Hollywood
on the back of "Ambition."
And a couple of things, I got
to show the competition first
and then you.
But the end of the year
videos, this is Facebook.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Stop defining each
other by what we are not,
and start defining
ourselves by who we are.
We can all be freer.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
And then yours
starts-- well, it's
halfway through, of course--
a little more bizarrely.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Just rendezvousing
with this comet
is an extraordinary thing.
But we're going to
make discoveries
that no one's imagined yet.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So Bill Nye the Science
Guy, by the way.
So, just an amazing, amazing
thing to be involved in.
And it keeps on going.
I'm going to show
another three-minute film
to show another
way we've engaged,
and then I'll wind
up at the end.
It's a way we've engaged
and it happened by accident,
but it worked extremely well.
We've made a series of
films to engage with kids.
And you now know a
lot about the comet.
And see how much of what
I've told you actually
appears in this summary.
This is what happened
on the 12th of November.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Over 10 years has passed since
Rosetta and Philae launched
on their exciting
mission to comet 67P,
Churyumov-Gerasimenko.
After three months investigating
the comet from orbit,
it was time to send
Philae to its surface.
A long night of final
preparations lay ahead of them.
Finally, the moment everyone
had been waiting for arrived.
As the world held
its breath, Rosetta
moved into the exact
position needed
to make sure Philae would
reach the landing site
that scientists on
Earth had picked
up earlier in the mission.
Philae and Rosetta were sad to
be going their separate ways,
but excited at the same time.
Because this is what they
had been waiting to do.
Philae was away.
It would take seven hours
to reach the surface,
but Philae wanted to get started
on his measurements right away.
He could soon see the
surface in incredible detail.
And the moment he
had been dreaming of
had finally arrived.
He had reached the
surface of the comet.
But all was not right.
His harpoons did not fire.
Philae realized he
couldn't relax yet.
He was rising from
the surface again.
Philae was scared he might
drift off the comet completely.
This was not in the plan.
But eventually, he
came back down again.
However, as he looked
around, he realized
he had landed in a completely
unexpected location.
Philae immediately set to
work on studying his new home.
It took him just over two days
to conduct all the experiments
he had brought with him.
After all his hard work,
Philae began to feel tired,
so he made sure to send all
the data he had collected back
to Rosetta.
As the sun set over
Philae's new home,
he fell into a deep sleep,
safe in the knowledge
that he did his main job
well and that his family
of comet-chasing heroes would
be proud of his achievement.
Who knows?
Perhaps one day, enough sunlight
would fall on his new landing
site and wake him up so that
he could carry on investigating
this incredible world.
And so, as the comet moved
over closer to the sun,
Rosetta prepared for the next
part of her exciting adventure.
[APPLAUSE]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So the big question is,
where is Philae today?
We actually don't know.
It's up against
the shaded region.
We know pretty
clearly where it is.
It's flown over.
You can actually see
the two red dots.
The first one at
the top left corner
is where we touched down.
The second one is
the cliff we hit.
And we know we're roughly here.
In fact, we've refined
this a little bit better.
We do this through the
tomography ranging experiments
with the comet.
We know the timing
very accurately.
So we believe we're
somewhere in this region.
But you can see, there are
lots of little white dots
everywhere.
And we've been looking
at all the images.
Philae's roughly one or two
pixels in size at the closest
pictures we have-- incredibly
difficult to actually sort out.
We'll have a post out next
week showing a little bit
about that, where
we think we are.
But we haven't definitively
identified Philae.
We're waiting for
the sun to increase,
because as we get closer to
the sun, the energy increases,
we may recharge
Philae's batteries.
It may come back to
life this summer.
We're listening out.
We're hoping to hear from it.
At the moment, we haven't.
Just to show you
what we're really
doing in studying the
surface of the comet,
this is an amazing image taken
during a very close flyby
on Valentine's Day.
We flew six kilometers
above the surface.
And again, you see these
incredible structures
and incredibly diverse terrain
in terms of mesas and plateaus
and dust and boulders.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: No,
crack's up around the neck.
But if you actually
look in more detail,
you get to see some
very interesting things
as we zoom in.
And the highest res picture
that we've released so far
is actually taken just
from about eight kilometers
above the surface.
And this is with the sun
right behind the back
of the spacecraft.
So you don't see
many of the shadows.
And in fact, what you
do see is Rosetta.
It's Rosetta's his own shadow,
from six kilometers up--
eight kilometers up.
And so we're in this position
now where we investigate
things absolutely
astonishing, sort
of [INAUDIBLE] alien landscape.
I mean, this is kind of science
fiction from the 1950s in terms
of the pictures.
And it really looks like this.
But more importantly
for us now is it's
starting to look like this.
Every day we take
a picture of it,
we are seeing more
and more jet activity,
more material flowing away.
This is the material which then
comes out tens of thousands
of kilometers away,
flows out into the tail,
which we should then be able
to see behind the comet.
I hesitated there.
We won't be able to see this
comet naked eye from the Earth.
It's never going to
be bright enough.
25 centimeter
telescope will do it.
But you don't need that.
We're there.
We're actually there.
And just one last
picture before I finish.
This is one we
released last week.
Over a space of three minutes,
we saw a jet come out,
two pictures, three
minutes apart.
And we see jet emission.
So we're really in this
fantastic phase now.
We'd love for Philae to
wake up, but you know what?
It doesn't matter.
We have Rosetta there,
doing amazing things.
So let me wind up.
We're at this point now where
we're actually flying by.
We're learning to
live with this comet.
The closest approach,
what's called perihelion,
is on the 13th of August.
That's the date at
which-- nothing really
happens, apart from the
closest point to the sun.
We are currently funded
to the end of this year,
but we think we should
be no problem continuing.
We have enough fuel on board
to run until late next year.
But as you think about
it, we'll be coming out
of the solar system again.
So we have to choose-- do
we go back into hibernation?
Nobody likes that idea.
So actually, what we're
currently investigating
is whether we can land
Rosetta on the surface
and have it all over again.
The only problem
is, of course, we
won't have another
spacecraft to talk to.
So once Rosetta hits
the ground, it's over.
But it will be a
fun day, I think.
Lots of social media--
all the good stuff there.
And it's not over.
And let me end by thanking you
for letting me come and take
your time today.
Everybody else watching out
there, thanks very much.
But I'm just standing in front
of a mission of thousands
of people across Europe,
across the world.
United States is involved.
NASA's involved.
A lot of people have
become involved making
movies and all sorts of stuff.
Lots of big media--
and my communications
team, who've done a lot of
the stuff you've seen here.
They made it just
a privilege for me
to be here today and
say, thank you very much
and keep watching the mission.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: One question regarding
the satellites-- so obviously,
changes during the orbits--
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: Rosetta
flying around the comet?
AUDIENCE: No, the comet
flying around the sun.
You didn't comment on how
it would feel for a human
if you were standing there.
Like, how bright or
dark would that be?
Would it be like you were
in the middle of night?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: Well,
at its closest point--
AUDIENCE: What's
the lumens like?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: Well,
at its closest point
it's between the Earth and Mars.
So it's roughly like a sunny day
on the Earth, roughly speaking,
because the atmosphere
absorbs some light.
I always make this joke that
when we're out at Jupiter,
we don't have enough power to
run the solar panels and so on.
Actually, Jupiter the
sunlight intensity
is roughly the same as a typical
British summer day under cloud.
So we have an enormous dynamic
range in sunlight on the Earth,
whether it's cloudy or not.
But it would be cold,
of course, because you
would be radiating to space.
You've got a cold object
next to you as well.
AUDIENCE: One short one-- where
does the outgassing start?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: Well,
we see it happening
from many parts of the surface.
We see it specifically
in certain areas.
AUDIENCE: Apart from
the sun, I meant.
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: Oh.
We saw it, actually, already
at three astronomical units.
The astronomical unit is the
distance between the Earth
and the sun, 150
million kilometers.
We saw that initial outburst--
actually at more like 3
and 1/2 AU.
So activity can
happen at any time.
It depends very much on
a particular fortuitous
orientation with respect
to accumulated sunlight
on a given day and maybe
a pocket of volatiles
near the surface,
expanding and blowing up.
So activity-- we've seen
Halley, the activity
continued a long way
out after perihelion.
So activity can happen, but it
goes as the square, roughly,
as the distance or the inverse
square with the sunlight.
And there's also
thresholds where
volatiles reach
certain temperatures
and suddenly get busy.
So we're seeing a
lot more activity
now than at the beginning.
AUDIENCE: So does Philae have
cameras that can point back out
in space if it wakes up?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: No.
What it has on board is seven
cameras around the outside,
which two are stereo.
It's a stereo pair.
But they look horizontally.
And then it has
cameras pointing down.
That having been said, we are
tilted at an angle like this,
and we know that we
can see in space.
When we did the
first panorama, we'd
see very dark material under us
an illuminated cliff and then
the sky, the point being--
AUDIENCE: Philae
gets ejected because
of outbursts, then when it
wake up and then [INAUDIBLE]?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN:
That's always possible.
I mean, we're in a
very shaded spot.
One of the ironies
is that, in fact,
if we had landed
on the surface, we
calculated that by
March this year,
we would have got too hot for
the electronics on the inside.
And by actually
being in the shade,
we're pretty cold
soaking, mind you.
That's one of the big worries.
We've been in cold
soak for a long time.
The electronics may be fried
or inverse fried-- unfried,
if you like-- chilled.
So we don't really know.
But if it does
come back to life,
we may be there at
a more active phase.
So this business of, will it
get ejected if there's activity
locally-- it's always possible.
But it's very tenuous.
If you think about the
ejected material from comets,
it's actually about the
same density as the Earth's
atmosphere, 100 kilometers up.
So it's just not like a strong
wind or anything like that.
There's very little force
from the-- we see it.
We sit on the solar panels.
When we're close in, we actually
feel the wind blowing us
and moving us around.
We are able to sense that.
AUDIENCE: OK, Mark, thanks
for this brilliant talk.
And my question is, you
showed in the last image
this jet that came up,
three second thing.
So what's the origin of it?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: It's
not really understood.
I mean, this is a
fairly wide field image
taken from a distance.
It may be there's a promontory
which just moved into sunlight
as it tipped, as the
base of the comet
tipped into sunlight there.
Nobody knows yet.
It's being looked at.
But we expect to start seeing
very transient effects.
We know that comets,
of course, occasionally
just go through big outbursts.
AUDIENCE: Jets everywhere
in the universe.
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: Jets
everywhere, exactly.
Indeed.
We take this one-- no,
you've got the mic.
AUDIENCE: So your best
case and scariest scenario
is that the comet
breaks in half.
If that happens, have you
modeled what's likely to Occur
Is there risk to the spacecraft?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN: It's
an interesting one.
People actually think
it may not fall apart
under centrifugal force,
which you would think.
It may actually slump
and fall together.
It's all going to be very slow.
The centrifugal force is
roughly the same as the gravity.
So there's not going to be any
balls on the end of a string,
you cut the string and
they fly off into space.
It's going to be a slow
motion activity, at best.
And at the moment, at least,
we're 100, 200 kilometers away,
routinely.
We have an issue at the
moment, interestingly,
that in order to maintain
our orientation as we
fly through our hyperbolic
flybys, well, always
we use star trackers on board.
We recognize
constellations on the sky,
compare them to a
catalog on board.
And as we fly through
the comet's coma now,
we see dust
particles everywhere.
And we're seeing
too many of those.
And we're confusing
them with stars.
And we're not able at the moment
to fly that close to the comet.
So we're still looking at this.
If you know any people that have
got 10 years old assembler code
expertise on star trackers--
somebody here, right?
It's an issue.
We're actually looking
to how we might
be able to reprogram
the star tracker.
It's very difficult to do.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
for the Mars Rover.
AUDIENCE: What
scientific questions
do you hope to answer in the
remainder of the mission?
MARK MCCAUGHREAN:
Well, I think there's
this issue of
overall composition,
particularly of organics, this
discussion about amino acids,
for example.
We know that on previous comets
that glycine has been seen.
But glycine is an
interesting amino acid,
because it's the only
one that's not handed.
It's not chiral.
The crucial thing is all life
on Earth is one-handedness.
And if we go and we
see the comets are
all handedness in their
amino acids as well,
that's an interesting thing.
It's unlikely to be the case.
It has to do with how
life evolved on the Earth
and picked one handedness
over the other.
But if there's a slight
predominance of one-handedness
over the other in the comets,
that would be very interesting.
It's really to study the
comet's evolution over time,
to try to understand
the amount of wastage,
the amount of erosion that
happens during one perihelion
passage.
What are the structures?
How does the outgassing occur?
Where does it come from?
Trying to understand how
comets are put together
by effectively seeing them
fall apart, if you like.
And we've never been
able to do that before.
We've never been able
to fly with a comet
over an extended period and see
the before and after changes.
And we'll watch it as it
cools down as well, of course.
We come out from the
sun after August,
we'll see how some of
those processes reverse
and how the dust settles
back down on the surface.
So in that sense, it's not
the high end questions,
are we made of comets stuff.
But for scientists,
this is exactly what
we love to do-- go
out and investigate
weird and wonderful objects,
take them apart, and tell
our friends about it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]